hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I just check it in on you what's going
on how are you I'm [ __ ] ah I didn't
want to get into it we're up to episode
10 I have no life I'm trying to [ __ ] in
trying to get in a quick workout before
I go to work because I am [ __ ] right
back up to where I was last year when I
was like a buck 86 187 I am you know it
kills me I've been working out why do
you work out you're so good online um
you know it is it's late night I'm
coming home I'm eating like a fat chick
you know meeting like some sad fellow
doesn't like himself
I just come home and I'm [ __ ] fried I
get home at like 7 o'clock at night and
I go [ __ ] it that's what I say
I get all the way to my street going I'm
going to get a salad I'm going to have a
protein I'm going to [ __ ] eat a bag
of beans or whatever and then I just
drive into my driveway and I go yeah
right i order [ __ ] pizza or burger
you know or I have a beer or something
like that and at my age yet that's it
that's it I go to my look like I'm on my
[ __ ] second trimester right now ah
this is my wife the other day we went to
a [ __ ] mall which is something I
never do go into a [ __ ] mall right
you know people go to the malls people
with children I get it you get them out
there they [ __ ] watch the trolley go
by and you know Santa Claus is there
right just [ __ ] sit there waiting for
you to put your kid in his lap you
[ __ ] weirdos right hey let's keep the
lie going to the point we put our child
in some [ __ ] perverts [ __ ] lap so
they think he comes down the goddamn
chimney me yes is it any wonder so many
people end up in cars they don't want to
be in with that saw that's how you start
out their life you know some [ __ ]
dude we don't know
you know don't really talk to sort of
God like you know sort of cult e-bike
Charlie Manson hair all [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] coming in and everything's cool
you go sit in his [ __ ] lap but don't
talk to strangers right
I don't I don't [ __ ] I'm just so
whatever we go to this [ __ ] thing and
we're walking by the fountain right
there's a trolley and a fountain this is
like the [ __ ] gayest place you could
ever go to and I don't mean gay in like
the homophobic way I mean the way it
used to mean like the 1890s the gay 90's
as in oh my god could a decade get any
happier right
it was everything but [ __ ] showgirls
coming down you know like the end of the
Family Guy song that was the only thing
that was missing and I just was like
what is all the excitement were [ __ ]
everybody's here buying pants why are we
having a [ __ ] parade you know so I
went in and I took her to go see the
other secret lives of pets which I
really enjoy because you know I'm a dog
I love [ __ ] dogs and you know what I
was curious what does my dog do when I
leave evidently they have quite the
adventures now is a [ __ ] really good
movie I liked it and does a bunch of
kids in there screaming and yelling and
that's what I wanted you know what I
mean
I went to the matinee show and I just
have a bunch of kids screaming yeah I
wanted the full effect of watching that
[ __ ] movie you know what I mean it's
like when you go to a horror movie you
got to go see it and there's going to be
a bunch of people yelling at the screen
right and you know that that's part of
the [ __ ] experience if you want to go
see some movie what everybody shuts the
[ __ ] up you know you got to do it in
your house maybe slap a few people
around before the movie starts you know
set the tone daddy ain't putting up with
this [ __ ] right so anyways long story
show and I dressed up a little bit when
I went down there you know I've been
working a lot so going to take out my
lady so when we're walking out we're
going by the fountain you know and
there's like all you know like the plane
like [ __ ] Tony Bennett if I ruled the
world every day would be like the first
day of spring
every douche would have such a wonderful
song to sing if I ruled the world what a
wonderful world
would be everybody's just saying that
mesmerised eating this [ __ ] ice cream
and [ __ ] yeah you bide pants
it was [ __ ] weird man it was like
when you go to this you go to some of
these [ __ ] balls it's like you're in
a Christmas special I'm telling you I
wouldn't be surprised if they got a
[ __ ] mr. right and they're putting
some sort of like like little little
dopamine in the air and you get like
this [ __ ] high and all of a sudden
you're like you know and I already have
[ __ ] 9 pairs of pants one more I'm
into double digits seven days in the
week I want the overlap I'm gonna go
over the bar life right like Vinnie
Colaiuta in a pants way um so anyway so
I go all right I'm gonna I don't know
what hat came over me we walked by the
fountain I said I let's get a picture
she's like where she couldn't [ __ ]
believe it I was going to take a picture
next to in front of a fountain at a mall
this is not me behavior right of course
she's all over women love that time oh
my god that'd be so nice right you just
it just makes you want to start crying
like Oh what happened to me right so I
want to do is take a [ __ ] selfie
right right you know get up [ __ ]
heads in it my head taking up three
quarters of it because it's so [ __ ]
big and some douche has to come along to
tell you a little thick lip area for you
and I'm thinking no I want you to I
don't want to prolong this moment you
[ __ ] ass always your guy code of
course my wife goes oh my god that would
be great right so what does he do he
[ __ ] takes one oh let's get one more
for safety right takes another one oh my
god and then I look at this picture in
the [ __ ] horror that I see like
[ __ ] stomach pushing out the bottom
of my button-down shirt and then when
you really just know you're just getting
fat is that [ __ ] button right right
on your breastplate it looks like it's
doing the Iron Cross just trying to hold
both parts of the shirt together and I
look so [ __ ] bad I almost got mad at
my wife like you let me walk around
looking like that it's like I get that
you love me but you know how about a
little bit of tough love you know
a little hey yeah hey fatty cakes you
know you're really going to have waffles
again this morning Exhibit A right yeah
bust out a [ __ ] photo you took of me
nothing will make you lose weight like a
bad [ __ ] photo huh Jesus Christ you
know it's bad enough when they catch in
your own backyard you know but I'll tell
you you take a photo in public in front
of a [ __ ] fountain at a mall that has
a trolley while Tony Bennett's playing I
mean I'm glad I didn't look at it till I
got home I would have [ __ ] jumped it
done a sailor's dive right near the
bottom of that fountain now I'm too vain
to kill myself I'll just hang around
make everybody else miserable that's
what you do that's what you do oh by the
way I finally I watched the the record
of the the British Grand Prix
fascinating [ __ ] race with all the
rain there who's going to go in and
change the tires who's going to keep
going and buy [ __ ] lap seven
everybody changed their [ __ ] tires
right it kind of seems if you get pole
position you're basically going to win
the race these guys are so good and the
cars are so equal you can't I've never
seen nobody does two-stroke a race thing
where you're way in the back and all of
a sudden you know you pass three people
and you do the little ZZ Top [ __ ]
oleh move you know I'm a [ __ ] movie
he goes by three cars that are all
[ __ ] in line drafting each other and
I've watched enough NASCAR let's go buy
a Harry Gant car right Darrell Waltrip
Cale Yarborough I watched enough of that
[ __ ] - no - people are draft and they're
going to slingshot around you I'll tell
you what not when Burt Reynolds is there
I don't know what he did he take off his
toupee and stick his head out the window
make himself a little more [ __ ]
aerodynamic is that how he went by three
cars I don't know fastest chicken in the
south that [ __ ] does not happen in
Formula one if you're not one of the top
three [ __ ] drivers of the Illuminati
basically as far as I can tell the five
races I've ever watched from stat to
finish you're not going to win the
goddamn race you know unless the two
guys up front don't like each other and
they smash into each other Jesus Christ
what was Hamilton and Nico Rosberg right
the end of the [ __ ] race Lewis
Hamilton wins it right guys from [ __ ]
England everybody man or what
everybody's going [ __ ] nuts and as I
mentioned before those two don't like
each other though he's smashing into
each other so in the end they always
show the green room afterwards after
somebody won and it was just like they
didn't say one word to each other
[ __ ] me out fellows they didn't say
one I think the [ __ ] toto guy all I
want to do when I wake up in the morning
is for you your ass when he fought he
[ __ ] said the two of them down he
goes listen you [ __ ] all right I know
you went out there and you watch stroker
race I know you watch that Kenny Rogers
movie where he adopts to six kids but
never really legally and nobody had a
[ __ ] problem with that I know you
watch Days of Thunder all right this
ain't that this cost real [ __ ] money
stop smashing into each other all right
I'll take you back to Germany and I'll
reopen I can't go that far oh the
Germans you know I'm telling you right
now if you take out about ten years of
their history they're great people and
you pick one wrong guy that's what's so
scary about this [ __ ] this election I
think that they should make Trump and
Hillary both put on a Hitler mask matte
and mask put on a Hitler [ __ ]
mustache and whoever looks the closest
you vote for the other person you know
what the results may surprise you
somebody make a clickbait [ __ ] a
clickbait [ __ ] whatever the hell you
call the meme or the the [ __ ] vine
you know we put both the presidential
candidates in a Hitler mass Hitler
mustache why can't I talk this morning a
Hitler mustache the results may surprise
you and just you know whoever you're for
you just make the other person I guess I
don't I don't know I don't know how you
bring that one home you know all you
kids today oh you [ __ ] internet
superstars you know I went into a place
the other day to get some lunch a
[ __ ] salad with some chicken
right desperately trying to [ __ ]
bring down the belly you know [ __ ]
Moby Dick guess what I look like right
now
you know shaved head [ __ ] ghost white
body you know there's a lot of blubber
on me right now
you know if I was to swim in the ocean
my biggest fear would not be sharks you
know it'd be some hipsters out there
[ __ ] whale hunting because they
thought you know they were taking it
back right get [ __ ] harpoon there the
[ __ ] was I talking about oh yeah
so I wanted to go get this [ __ ] salad
and I'm standing in there's a guy in
line wearing a [ __ ] Versace robe Gold
Versace robe and slippers so I text my
wife going there's a dude in here you
know you want me to take a picture you
got to see this guy right so I [ __ ]
take a picture the guy she's like oh my
god my friend knows that person he makes
these vines alright so then I clicked on
his YouTube page and the guy's now
whatever Twitter page the guy's [ __ ]
hilarious and I'm just sitting there
this [ __ ] guy he doesn't need to be
in a writers room on each has his own
[ __ ] show and he gets to walk around
in his bathrobe and slippers all day
making cooking videos god bless him I
don't know what the point of all this is
I think the point of all this is I need
to get back on elliptical soon so I
don't have a [ __ ] hat attack before I
go to most of the Middle East before I
go to the [ __ ] UM go over to England
anyway so yeah I got a [ __ ] knock
dish I can knock out this podcast and
then I have a actually have some people
coming over here because our kitchens
all [ __ ] up you know what's wrong bill
what's wrong with the kitchen oh I don't
know whether you put on the hot water or
the cold water the hot water still comes
out you know problem I fixed [ __ ]
nine times you go to shut off the
[ __ ] hot water the handle comes off
cupboards are all falling apart you know
everything else in the house is pretty
much nice I probably shouldn't even say
that [ __ ] so I got it's like the final
[ __ ] thing I have to do you know what
I mean because I fixed up the rest of
the house I'm hoping it's the final
[ __ ] thing I have to do but if
for the most part I fixed up the rest of
the house and so now like the kitchen
has become like this I I saw you know be
like if you thought a brand new suit and
you had these old shitty shoes you know
and people look down they're just like
you know what I was going to get in
business with this guy but what the [ __ ]
is with those shoes you
well you [ __ ] Willy Loman there you
[ __ ] Willy Loman
so that nightmare project is about ready
to start people coming over today with
their ideas I have an idea like what if
we just took everything out and put new
stuff in in the exact same place except
for a couple of things and it cost you
[ __ ] three billion dollars how about
that I could be rustic yet modern yet
postmodern but kind of Art Deco ish but
doesn't compromise the integrity of the
structure I'm signing up for that [ __ ]
again but you know what though you know
I think probably put it into six weeks
in other words in about nine months I
think it ought to be done breathing in a
bunch of dust
I'll have [ __ ] Coal Miner's Daughter
long whatever the [ __ ] they call it I
have no idea we don't have any goddamn
mom I don't have any questions on this
one and I also don't have any
advertising you know I will do some
advertising here Tuesday night I went
back to the Troubadour and I saw wheeler
Walker jr. right you say it's over pack
up your stuff
something something you've had enough
that guy [ __ ] you [ __ ] you broke my
heart
[ __ ] you France tearing us apart
[ __ ] you dog open never comes home I saw
that guy [ __ ] live man it was one
what a fun [ __ ] show was great the
band's killer the bass player actually
plays in one of my favorite [ __ ]
bands Truth and salvage company he's on
the road with them at a killer band and
the dude comes out wheeler Walker jr. he
[ __ ] murdered it absolutely [ __ ]
murdered it I didn't know what
to expect when I went down you know when
somebody goes down there to doing funny
songs you like I don't know what's going
to happen here it's just going to be
like a one joke song and then you
[ __ ] like still standing there for
another 45 minutes it was it was great
he was [ __ ] hilarious in between
songs it's banded with the crowd what
I'm saying is if you get a chance to see
wheeler Walker jr. he's coming to a
[ __ ] club near you theater near you
arena booking ampie theater a carport
I don't know I'm trying to think of
every structure I could think of
definitely go out to see him he's
absolutely worth the money and then the
band sounds great and he had another
band open up in front of him two ladies
with guitars they were great
just [ __ ] kill a show and I ran to a
bunch of comics when I was there I ran
into Doug Benson and all these other
guys look at me dropping names here
dropping [ __ ] names and I sat there
in the back of the club and I just drank
water all night because I'm [ __ ] fat
I'm not gonna lie to you I had one
whiskey you know you got to have one you
know even John Wayne would have one you
know before he ate half a [ __ ] cow
that he barely cooked isn't that what
happened to him you know that's what you
know what happened all those guys back
in the day they just kept eating red
meat because back then it was all about
whoa you know why would I eat hamburger
when I got steak at home right didn't
know what they said weren't they
literally talking about food considering
what most of them died of I know that
was about their ladies but anyways back
then right if you were like a guy's guy
you were eating steak if you were [ __ ]
if you were successful it was considered
the highest kind of [ __ ] meat know
that you didn't realize it was tearing
apart your [ __ ] guts and back then
there's no way you let another man
[ __ ] look in your ass to make sure
you weren't going to die of ass cancer
right there's no [ __ ] way you could
do that and then get on a horse and call
yourself a cowboy that's not what what
it was about
all right you kept eating steak and you
when you and you would your wife was
done making the steak you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Raptor with the frying pan I
said cleanup right then you went over
you put butter on the steak and then
that was it and I think it was better
for the environment back then you know
what I mean
women were being beaten so they were
drinking themselves to death so they
died earlier and guys [ __ ] ate
themselves to death and you know people
got out of the way and there was only
like [ __ ] a couple billion people on
the planet now look at everybody
everybody's doing yoga nobody's beating
their wives right everybody's having a
[ __ ] salad and now there's seven and
a half billion people on the [ __ ]
planet you know and I think it's high
time that we go back to the way it was
you know or whatever well let Hillary
becomes president and at the end of a 48
year run then it goes back to the
[ __ ] Dark Ages we go back to a feudal
system the real one
you know where you're actually aware of
what was happening rather than now where
it's just bankers [ __ ] silently
sucking the life out of the [ __ ]
middle claw of Jesus bill you're going
to get on a [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
kills me Bernie Sanders arguably the
scientists from back to the future
[ __ ] endorses Hillary Clinton you
know can you [ __ ] any of them can any
of them just [ __ ] have a point of
view and just stick with it always like
this is what I'm above you can vote for
me because I'm above this right and then
the second all of a sudden they start
taking on water or this or the thing
that's working speaking of water do you
know there's more shark attacks than
ever they're doing [ __ ] stories about
what should we do about this it's like
well you know you could not swim in the
ocean you dumb [ __ ] there's plenty of
[ __ ] plenty of lakes you know what I
mean you know [ __ ] fill up your bathtub
you know have make it data you know put
a snorkel on it stare at your balls I
mean do whatever you got to do but don't
go in the [ __ ] water all right what
do you think there's more shark attacks
now well two reasons one there's more
[ __ ] people and two we're eating all
the [ __ ] fish so the menu is becoming
more limited you know back in the day
shark could be like I look at that
[ __ ] surf
or yeah you know the [ __ ] board gets
between my teeth it's not that tough for
me you know he's doing Pilates and I
asked well you know look at that school
of tuna torille torille right I'm going
to go over there and [ __ ] have some
tuna all those options aren't there
anymore and these people still go out
there and they're boogie boards right do
you go out on a boogie board you're like
a slider like children children on
boogie boards that's like a slider now
for a [ __ ] shark and then you get to
the you get to the bigger people you
know I'll tell you right now how fat I
am there's no [ __ ] way I would go out
there they'd think I was a [ __ ] sea
lion an albino sea lion that got shunned
by the rest of the herd you know is
there anything worse than watching a
[ __ ] animal on one of those animal
shows getting shunned by the rest of the
herd you know animals are like super
[ __ ] racist I don't know what it is
the second somebody is a [ __ ] albino
they show a little bit of weakness I
mean they're really terrible people you
never hear PETA bring that up
I mean sure they sit there and they talk
about how bad human beings are hey you
know guilty as charged
you're looking at it Ivy I've gone down
to [ __ ] Kentucky Fried Chicken I've
eaten that because chicken you know all
walking around roided up like McGwire
and [ __ ] Sosa fallin on their [ __ ]
faces because people like the white meat
more you know I've eaten that [ __ ]
guilty as [ __ ] charged but what they
don't talk about it's how those [ __ ]
chickens if they were allowed to keep
their beaks you know and not have chests
so big that they fell down they would be
bullying the [ __ ] weakest hen you
know you don't deserve to have children
right just go over and they pecker to
death and they never you know they go
you know that's just how they are
you know it's survival of the fittest
and all that [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden human beings start doing it right
some [ __ ] nerd gets thrown into a
locker and all of a sudden it's this
national [ __ ] story
I think one human beings is going to
turn around today we just submit that
we're just a bunch of [ __ ] animals
you know I have no idea what I'm talking
about I just I have not looked at any
news I don't know what this [ __ ]
pokemons
thing is about everybody's talking about
it I finally asked somebody at work I
know that there's like I know it was a
movie I know kids were into it I guess
there's people running around with their
phones trying to find the pokemons
to capture the middle of the [ __ ] day
we were in the writers room and these
kids ran up to this dumpster and it was
like a [ __ ] Wednesday afternoon like
don't you have to go to work shouldn't
you be somewhere right now get out of me
should be out there blaming your parents
for something I don't know it's really
making that poke Pokemon things really
making me feel old everybody like it's
going around a lot of people going
around doing it and then there's people
watching people doing it so it's like
they're not doing anything and then
you're watching them doing nothing it's
kind of [ __ ] weird right it's like I
saw this thing the other day you know on
rollercoasters now that some of the new
rollercoasters to having people get on
the roller coaster and then you put on
virtual reality glasses right it's like
it's not enough to be on the roller
coast and then you got to be on the put
the glasses on and you go up the hill
and then as you go over the top and you
have that big drop they make it feel as
though you're falling off of a building
or something it's like well you know
you're kind of doing that in real life
why don't you take them off and enjoy it
I don't you know what it is it's all of
us just slowly but surely working our
way to robots you know having a robot
mom and dad and these [ __ ] you know I
ran into some nerd the other day that
was in the [ __ ] robotics believe it
or not did this benefit for that tragedy
they are in Orlando right you guys
remember that tragedy is there been 52
more [ __ ] shootings since then that
people don't even remember it right so
we did a benefit for that and I'm
standing out in the alley afterwards
having a [ __ ] cigar right and this
kid comes up I call him a kid that means
he was like 26 years old and he was
[ __ ] talking about how he said the
robotics and all this type of [ __ ] and I
was just like why are you doing that
what does no way he wasn't into robotics
what the [ __ ] was he
- it was into some [ __ ] that would just
basically gather information on the user
without the person really knowing it and
it's just like why why are you doing it
you know and he's going well but bla bla
bla bla bla and I just kept hammering
them with the questions and hammer him
with the questions and at the end of the
day the only way he could defend what he
what he was doing was he basically said
this well you know if I didn't do it
someone else would right there that's
the devil's that's the devil song right
there heigh-ho heigh-ho if I didn't do
it someone else would it doesn't rhyme
who gives up [ __ ] I hope let's go
[ __ ] do something evil that's
might've been the worst song ever if you
have to justify your [ __ ] job by
basically saying you know if I didn't do
it somebody else would what jobs are
those spying on people dealing drugs
right [ __ ] I don't know what shooting
poor know dropping bombs I mean any time
the only way to justify your job is if I
didn't do it somebody else would and you
know I don't know but these [ __ ]
[ __ ] making these robots man they're
making them too good I used to do a bit
about it you know that basic you know I
don't mind if you make the [ __ ] thing
super smart just don't have it be able
to run like [ __ ] bo Jackson which is
what they're doing because they keep
trying to improve it and they're [ __ ]
competing with somebody else some other
companies [ __ ] robot and they're just
making the thing into the six million
dollar man it's like guys guys you
already stuck every [ __ ] answer to
any question ever in between it's
[ __ ] non-existent metal [ __ ] ears
I guess it has metal is non-existent
human ears and now you're going to be
able to make it run a [ __ ] 440 you
know like this this thing knows the
answers to everything right you know and
it can make the [ __ ] Seahawks
secondary that's that's what the [ __ ]
you're building and you don't think that
that's going to come back and bite us in
the ass it knows the answer to
everything
so it basically knows how to do
open-heart surgery and also how to load
and fire and ak4
seven fly and f-16
I mean it's limitless like you remember
those [ __ ] action movies where like
the [ __ ] this the the hero the movie
I don't care what kind of mode of
transportation a [ __ ] boat
a helicopter a motorcycle the Space
Shuttle this [ __ ] guy knows how to
use it no pre-flight you just start the
[ __ ] helicopter up you yank the guts
out of it you know I took a ride in a
[ __ ] a-star the other day and I
there's no firework I wouldn't be able
to figure out how to [ __ ] start that
thing up I got over I got like a 120
hours flying a Robinson 22 you stick me
in an a-star it's like egg kids little
help these [ __ ] Rambo guys these
Steven Seagal guys these muscle from
brussels guys chuck norris right eddie
deezen all of them they just [ __ ] ran
up and could just do it and used to
always laugh going that's [ __ ] bull
anybody you know if you had a boat you
just be like well i want to footage know
where the [ __ ] keys were just jumps
right into [ __ ] keys right there he
knows exactly where the [ __ ] throttle
is he doesn't have to look around and
get his bearings like hey this is this
that's that he just [ __ ] jumps in
like it's his boat and it always makes
you laugh going yet that would never
happen in real life well guess what in
2016 that's going to happen these
[ __ ] robots I don't know why they
would be running away they're not going
to be running away from us they can be
running after us and you know if they
get sick a [ __ ] run in which why
would they they don't have a respiratory
system as long as it charged up like a
[ __ ] Tesla they're never going to
stop but it doesn't make a difference
what mode of transportation what weapon
is near by that was another thing with
those action heroes whatever [ __ ]
they they pick up a goddamn gardening
hoe and all of a sudden they're spinning
it around like Bruce Lee it's like Jesus
when you in band you went you were a
majorette too you had time to [ __ ]
master all the martial arts learn how to
use not only every mode of
transportation
every [ __ ] aberration of that [ __ ]
mode of transportation is that the right
word
you know every style of [ __ ] boat I
don't give a [ __ ] if it's sailing if
it's a submarine or a [ __ ] cruise
ship you know how to get that [ __ ]
thing going and to dock it and tie it
off all at the same [ __ ] time right
these robots can do that but at least
Rambo least Rambo bled he had to take
time to [ __ ] sell himself back up
these robots don't we think bleeds we
can commit the [ __ ] robots don't
believe you know what I mean and you
know these [ __ ] nerds you know back
in the day he poured a Dixie cup of
water on down their back you know and
they didn't do like a person lift their
shoulders up and go all right they don't
they [ __ ] short-circuit out and then
they fall down so you know what these
nerds are doing they're like well we
can't have that
you know the competition's robot if you
dump a little bit of water down its back
it shorts out and there goes [ __ ] a
zillion dollars with the technology you
know that they're making they're going
to make these full [ __ ] robots
they're going to make them be able to
swim right to everything it's going to
be just like that [ __ ] movie well
that guy had all those [ __ ] lady
robots and he was [ __ ] him and [ __ ]
right and then one kid gets locked in
the breezeway and he's screaming like I
thought you loved me and she just goes
away with the expressionless look on her
face that's what they're going to do I
guarantee I bet you right now as I'm
talking somebody somewhere is [ __ ] a
robot they know it's got the lab coat on
and [ __ ] so he makes him feel like he's
doing research and there's a bunch of
other scientists watching them [ __ ]
the robot right and then afterwards he's
going to give the feedback oh no you
know what it is it's a [ __ ] it's
probably just some regular person who
has like Hep C but can't afford that
1095 dollar pill to get rid of it as
somebody hiv-positive so they go hey man
you want that [ __ ] pill you got to
come in here and [ __ ] this robot on film
well this last thing I'll tell you I got
to go to work did you [ __ ] see have
you seen this evidently I don't know if
this is [ __ ] true but ever sent Lee
the pharmaceutical lobbyists any states
where weed is legal they're going after
the legalization of weed because any any
state where weed is legal
prescriptions go down I don't know if
this is true but somebody told me it was
and I never looked up any information so
I'm going to say it's true and I owe big
apology to all the [ __ ] weed smokers
out there evidently you were right so
anyways but I'm going to keep drinking
I'm too far down this [ __ ] road all
right I got to get out of here I got to
go to [ __ ] work and knock out this
last [ __ ] one for Christ's sake
that's the podcast you [ __ ] I will talk
to you on Thursday I'll check in on you
alright go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll see
you Thursday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast for
the week of July 10th 2008 is it July
10th I have no idea I just got off a
plane coming back from LA from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
I flew US air I sat and c18 a and there
were two people about oh I don't know 19
rows behind me talking really loudly you
know those people they laugh at
everything that they say and they never
say anything funny four hours of that
[ __ ] four [ __ ] hours of that people
just going you know how many hours are
left on the flight I don't know four and
a half haha it just start laughing
it was [ __ ] killing me was it was
torture Oh flight I ended up doing I got
a new battery for my made of wood laptop
so I was able to watch Goodfellas so I
was able to drown her out for how long
is good fella's huh so like two hours
long or some [ __ ] so I had that on had
Goodfellas on crank as high as I could
you know we did what we wanted we were
wise guys I had that [ __ ] crank as
high as I could to try to drown out this
ridiculous group of people I don't know
I you know what I mean maybe it's me
maybe I'm so [ __ ] miserable you know
am I so miserable that I actually need
something to be funny to laugh at you
know I mean I was sitting there in the
end of it trying you know when they
finally you know actually I didn't watch
the end of an end of Goodfellas I hate
when he's when he [ __ ] becomes a
druggie you know what I mean he just
pisses me off you know and then he then
he feels like all feels like he's the
victim you know six thousand bucks for a
low-life for work he gives me six grand
you like he didn't [ __ ] blow your
brains out right there he told you not
to [ __ ] with the drugs the exact [ __ ]
thing he told you not to do
you went out you did it and then he ends
up throwing to jail and dying in jail
you piece of [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate at the
beginning of that movie is great right
up through the wizard the Lu Enza
[ __ ] robbery that movie is awesome
and then the second his second he gets
that coke [ __ ] in that flophouse
apartment and then he's got that [ __ ]
with the attitude though the girl there
the [ __ ] babysitter I got to get my
hat I don't know I don't know so anyway
that's what I was doing I was [ __ ]
listening to that movie on tenth Janice
Rossi is Aurora I had that [ __ ]
blasting in my ears one of my ears is
ringing right now I already had tinnitus
in one ear from playing drums years ago
and [ __ ] it's going to be ringing
even more because of these [ __ ]
idiots man I just I don't know does
anybody you know you got anybody who
does that [ __ ] they just you know they
come walking up and you would be sitting
there waiting for an elevator and they
just go hey how you doing you're like
good and like a good yeah
you know if you don't anybody [ __ ]
Luke does that at work just discretely
leave a book on self-confidence in their
little cubicle area something you know
what I mean people you to do that
although they say oh they they hum songs
I think I already joked about that about
28 podcasts ago but for those of you who
are new to my podcast I used to work
with a guy you even work with someone
who hums a tune that doesn't exist you
know what I mean
skies to walk around the office dee dee
dee ba ba boo doo dee dee all [ __ ]
day long and I see like what the [ __ ]
that's not a song right it's not a
stress I like a song when I hummed it
yeah exactly but that's a dead-on
rendition of his [ __ ] you know it just
it went on forever like one of those
progressive prog rock bands a Dave
Matthews a Simon concert [ __ ] was it's
terrible somebody hooked me up with
tickets and it was one of those those
bands that you get after [ __ ] a song
and a half
and then there's a black guy playing a
fiddle which is which is weird you know
I select random [ __ ] like that you know
like seen a fat Asian yeah you don't see
that too often you know black guy
playing a feral you know should be like
should be four you know isn't that but
you think that he would he would do it
the black guy way you know we're all of
a sudden he teaches white people that a
fiddle can actually be cool as opposed
to some you know redneck instrument or I
guess in classical music it's cool but
you know what I mean I mean black people
made happy birthdays make a cool sound
you know cool song you take it you know
that's what that's when I saw a black
guy with the fiddle that's what I
thought okay he's gonna he's gonna break
it down I thought something's going to
happen and he just was playing that skip
to my Lou spin your partner round to the
ride that that style I think the black
guy who plays the saxophone in the Dave
Matthews Band I bet he doesn't talk to
the black guy play the fiddle of
anything he's a sellout just coming up
some every show you know my [ __ ] it's
bad enough you'd be playing a
[ __ ] violin
you'd be doing that [ __ ] every night for
all these [ __ ] white people how
do you think that makes me feel it was a
worst impression of a black saxophone
player in a band that I don't like that
I'll ever do but I don't give a [ __ ] I
just got off a goddamn plane cut me some
slack I listen to people laugh they
always like a nightmare [ __ ] comedy
show you know I mean we're all of a
sudden it didn't it didn't make sense
anymore like you just said anything okay
can I get up I need to need to go to the
bathroom yeah okay hunt alright anyways
let's get on with the podcast here what
do we got here I'm what I'm going to do
this week we'll start with the questions
not [ __ ] then I want to I want to hike
the [ __ ] first first of all I just got
that from The Improv in Pittsburgh
unbelievable turnout and 99.9% of that
has to go to the gym and Randy show on
wdv those guys totally hooked me up they
let me come in on a Wednesday on a
Thursday and on a Friday I did like nine
hours of [ __ ] radio with those guys
letting everybody know that I was going
to be over at the stack
the mall over there and other than the
fact that a couple people got shot and
one was murdered I think was a good week
over there at the mall again it happened
one week one night we were out drinking
and all of a sudden Lee couldn't leave
them all because somebody gets shot
which is [ __ ] unbelievable staying
within a stone's throw of a stone store
no pun intended a Cold Stone Creamery
that's not supposed to happen is it when
you you know when you see a Fuddruckers
right I just thought I just don't
associate that with violence but anyways
I had a great week out there and I want
to thank all the guys over at dve for
hooking me up and everybody who came out
to see me
also once again to remind you I have a
one-hour special coming out on Comedy
Central August 23rd all right Sega TiVo
six weeks ahead for some reason my
[ __ ] CD comes out before the special
which makes no sense to me but I believe
that's in stores on August 5th and then
the DVD comes out I think September 14th
I know it's bizarre you guys are going
to be sick of me by mid-september
but anyways please check it out I'm
really proud of the special we shot it
ourselves
tell your friends to watch it and
whatever
hopefully they become fans of what I do
and then they show up in my shows and
someday I can afford to take a private
jet at the very least set up in first
class where I can afford those Bose
headset where I can drown out people if
they [ __ ] laugh and a budget that
isn't funny alright let's get on with
the podcast questions if you new to my
podcast this is what I do every week I
babble I [ __ ] about people in airports
I answer questions i riff about the Dave
Matthews Band and I hide my [ __ ] I don't
rip about the Dave Matthews Band I don't
even know any of the [ __ ] songs I
just know I know crash into you yeah
baby and I come into you he really is
like disgusting lyrics when you really
think about it but these things on these
things are nicely I don't like that
little James Brown [ __ ] jig he does
either when he sit there
this acoustic guitar I never really
noticed how much I didn't like that band
you know what I'm not to think about
this I like it back if you have to get
back to you guys on this one listen I'm
stuttering I'm so [ __ ] annoying from
that flight maybe I'm really just pissed
at the people on the plane and I'm
taking it out on the Dave Matthews Band
misdirected anger all right let's get
into the questions here people I got to
make this one a quick one because I got
a bunch of [ __ ] I got to do today
and one of them is to fix my attitude
alright question number one a bill I
have a question for your podcast why
don't you just ask it okay that's like
people go let me tell you something so
he's just [ __ ] saying it actually I
think I do that alright I have a
question for your podcast being a comic
from New York City which coast do you
think is best for stand-up comedy first
of all I am NOT a comment from New York
City I'm a comment from Boston
Massachusetts who then moved to New York
City
okay I would is what sequester which
coast do I think is best for stand-up
comedy oh Christ I don't know there you
go how's that for [ __ ] a bad answer
New York City if you just want to become
a great comic there's nothing better
than New York City
it's got like 9 million clubs you can do
like 10 sets a night if you want not 10
you could do 10 but I think
realistically you do 7 or 8 once you run
with all the clubs at least you could
back in a day I just keep digressing
with everything I'm saying so I would
say New York was great and then there's
other other cities that are good to
start out in which is uh Boston was
great Houston's always have a good scene
Denver San Francisco Seattle's bunch of
funny guys there Minnesota's got a great
scene um yeah you know what I mean I
worked in Atlanta I don't know if you
funny just get your [ __ ] together but I
guess you're asking me should you move
to New York City or LA you I would visit
both places before you went out there
because I don't know New York City just
felt like home when I went there and
when I went to LA you know the weather
was great everything was cool but it was
you know I stood in line for [ __ ]
nine hours to do way yet the sign
for a three-minute spot at the Laugh
Factory and I had a [ __ ] sunburn I got
there at 9:00 in the morning for a sign
up that was at 6:00 at night this is no
[ __ ] right that right there on
sunset Avenue could take you guys down
memory lane so I'm sitting there and I
remember there was these two fat chicks
from [ __ ] Utah something that had
really bad tattoos I was third in lying
by 9:00 in the morning that's all I
remember
and yeah and I wasn't down there with
anybody else so I couldn't leave
other than quickly to go take a bathroom
break like it was literally a whole
system was a [ __ ] nightmare right
ended up getting a sunburn right on my
huge forehead and went home after I
signed up it six went back to the kids a
problem where I was staying showered
really quickly came back down and had to
do three minutes of stand-up which is
practically impossible you know what I
mean that's like trying to finish a bowl
of cereal in like two scoops you know so
I went down there and I don't know how
the [ __ ] I did it but I went onstage and
I absolutely [ __ ] destroyed for three
minutes I did a tight three-minute set
that had a beginning a middle and an end
probably because I only had like a half
hour material I knew I figured out how
to do it so I'm sitting there going like
oh man
I got off stage I was like that's it I'm
in at this club I'm going to get a
manager this is you know everything's
going to happen and then I went upstairs
and I met the infamous Jamie Masada who
clothes everybody body so I'm sitting
there and he had his table when I sit
down at his table I'm thinking this
guy's just going to kiss my ass you know
from some young book I went up there
[ __ ] destroyed I was better than you
know the two fat chicks from Utah this
is it it's over right so I sit down you
know my egos through the [ __ ] roof
and he's just like I don't he sat there
stared at me for a second he had his
hands together like not in a fist but
sort of like he's doing the church and
the steeple thing except all his things
are up and he had his index fingers up
on his mouth and he just goes
you're very funny and I was like oh
thank you very much I'm like okay here
comes it comes here comes he's gonna has
to manage me right and he's like you
know you talk you talk a lot about a lot
about your father yeah yeah I go yeah
yeah you think you should do more you
should do more about do more about your
father and I'm like oh yeah yeah you
know I got a ton of stuff about my dad I
got some more stuff about my mom and as
I'm saying that he holds my his hand up
to silence me at which point I literally
shut the [ __ ] up and he just goes your
father let me ask you a question how
does it make you feel when your father
yells and then he leaned back in his
chair right and it was like I felt like
he was going to give me the answer to
all my stand-up questions in the form of
a riddle and immediately I I began
grabbing the legs on the back of the
chair because I was going to smash it
over his [ __ ] head because I was so
[ __ ] I was so pissed I was like yeah I
just [ __ ] killed for three minutes
and now you can act like you to stand up
guru you jackass and that's exactly what
he did he didn't have to manage me
he just given me a riddle how does it
make you feel when your dad yells Jamie
I hope you listening to this because I'm
playing your club this week how do you
think it made me feel made me feel like
a baby feel sad is that what you wanted
to hear Jesus Christ this guy came at me
like one of those guys you ever see
those interviews when they interview
somebody after like a tornado hit their
house and killed their favorite dog you
know and then sitting there interviewing
them and they want him to cry and
they're not crying so then they got to
as they got to sit there and ask him
questions to try and make him [ __ ]
cry I think that's what he was trying to
do to me so I literally was grabbing the
back of the chair
the legs on the back I distinctly
remember doing that and I was like [ __ ]
this guy [ __ ] la I'm going to New York
that's how I ended up in New York one
three minutes set after nine hours and a
second-degree sunburn on my forehead I
decided that the East Coast was
place I needed to be in order me and you
know worked out well for me
you know what's funny somebody's
probably going to [ __ ] tell Jamie
that I actually said that [ __ ] just so
they can try to get a 3-minute audition
on Tuesday so this week when I go down
there Jamie's gonna be like buddy buddy
what do you what are you doing buddy I
actually love Jamie now man and I might
kissing his ass either because I don't
give a [ __ ] but he said the funniest
[ __ ] to me be it like three weeks ago
I'm working his club and I'm standing in
the lobby and these two gorgeous girls
you know la too [ __ ] gorgeous so I'm
looking at him you know i buggin out of
my head and Jamie's like body buddy
buddy what are you doing man or what do
you I go tomorrow what do you mean what
am i doing I go I'm looking at the girls
he goes yeah buddy but why are you
looking at the girls I go because
they're beautiful
I go why wouldn't I be looking at the
girls and he goes cuz you're a [ __ ] I
think I butchered that he said it even
better was the [ __ ] he so he totally
set me up son of a [ __ ] and if you live
in LA I'm going to be down there Tuesday
night Thursday night Friday night and
Saturday night all on the 10 o'clock
show and I'll be having a good time down
there alright so there you go see that I
trust Jamie then I tell a funny story
where he trashes me and then I hype his
club and then it's all good how do the
[ __ ] in show business I am I know how
to do it I not escape the [ __ ] life
all right
so that's what I would do son I would I
would go to New York and LA and figure
out which one you want to be in alright
that's it alright question number three
if you have any thoughts about doing a
European tour of your show absolutely I
feel that I'm in the conspiracy theory I
feel like they're crashing the dollar
and all these corporations they're all
going global so I'm going global with
them I'm not going to be caught
flat-footed with a pocket full of
currency that isn't worth a goddamn peso
so I'm actually set up a European tour
for the beginning part of next year or
at some point in 2009 I should say I
want to go over to England Sweden I did
some [ __ ] one time and
the Netherlands it's really disappointed
when I went to know Netherlands when I
got off the plane and the first thing I
saw was like a [ __ ] Dunkin Donuts you
know I mean and like a McDonald's it
just it just really is I understand why
people find America so annoying is
because the urban sprawl of our [ __ ]
corporations you know I mean I literally
think that I could go to like [ __ ]
let me pick take a [ __ ] nice obscure
country that already know where it is on
a map let me think of something and
Bosnian know in a way that's [ __ ]
Eastern Europe Bolivia and it was one of
those because I that's in South America
whatever you go to [ __ ] Bolivia you
think he can go down there and see that
[ __ ] that guy from the t-shirt that
everybody wears che guevara Gutierrez
whatever his name is
Valenzuela that [ __ ] guy and you go
down you get off what's the first thing
you see Colonel Sanders on a big bucket
of [ __ ] chicken I think that's what
Hugo Chavez is big [ __ ] I love that guy
man that guy's the [ __ ] you know what I
mean
those guys they remind me like Tony
Montana that that's what Hugo Chavez is
Hugo Chavez taken on the US knowing full
well that we could [ __ ] Nukem anytime
we wanted to talk and [ __ ] about us at
the UN he's like in his early Tony
Montana years you know before Jesus
Christ is done annoying he's in his
early Tony Montana years like right
before he gets the Cadillac with the
leopard skin you don't I mean when he's
still washing dishes with that that
[ __ ] Robin Williams Hawaiian shirt
that's what Hugo Chavez is right now all
right question number four this is very
little jet lag here people sorry I mean
[ __ ] blow through these and I'll stop
wasting your time all right question
number four uh god this one is a back
story yes I attempted to renew my Norton
AntiVirus I like I want me to sing a
song about Microsoft I can't I can't
remix this song student less they have a
song you don't I mean you got it you got
a you got to pick one
you got to pick a product that annoys
you that actually has a song and I will
do a [ __ ] Puff Daddy remix of it that
has the word continent
it will make you feel better alright
alright question number five hey Bill
here's a question have you ever had
people bring their kids to your shows
and I'm not talking eighteen years old I
mean like five years old
absolutely I've had people bring babies
and I've been in the middle of talking
about something really I don't know evil
probably my going to a titty bar and now
I hate that you know regular girls go to
titty bars now you know because they
killed the perverted vibe of the club I
was doing that bit talking about how
strip clubs are for [ __ ] only and then
I can't feel comfortable leering at a
stripper when I'm sitting next to
Melissa you know doing that joke and all
of a sudden I hear this baby baby
besides crying in the back and then it
you know something that's even more
awkward when they bring a kid that can
speak you know when I just say a five
five years old or over another than have
you guys picture mutes or something yeah
I've actually I've had people bring kids
I'm trying to think it hasn't happened
in a while there was actually a girl
this week in Pittsburgh she laughed like
a little kid so it was weird she sounded
like a little kid so it was freaking all
the comics out and then it turned out
she wasn't a little kid she was just an
adult with a really annoying voice and
then she came up to me afterwards and
she had these huge titties and she was
saying come on down to plush which is
some strip club in Pittsburgh and she
had that classic Anna Nicole Smith I'm
going to overdose in a hard rock cafe
voice so if she's listening I hope you
still alive he didn't OD did I ever tell
you that story I played the same hard
rock cafe good [ __ ] Anna Nicole Smith
died in I got to tell you something
that's been there for three [ __ ] days
I get it I think she killed herself I
don't think it was an overdose I think
you know an accidental I think she did
it on purpose
because that place sucks alright
question number seven though I recently
went to an open mic at my local comedy
club the first time just to watch the
club just to watch Jesus Christ nobody
puts capital letters anymore
or punctuation I just went right to the
next sentence bill I recently went to
the open mic night at my local comedy
club for the first time just to watch
the club only has open mic night once a
month which is gay but I can't do
anything about it anyway I figure most
of the most of the comics that got up
would suck and bomb maybe if you would
do okay but there were about 14 and 13
of them ended up doing really well this
was discouraging to me because I figured
most open microscope which would make me
feel better about myself and my commie
comedy is this how open mic was for you
please share your wisdom with me all
right
I'll share my stories wisdoms going a
little too far yeah that's what it's
like you go down there and there's
people who are still doing open mics but
they're they're better than being open
mic resent
but they still need the stage time and
you know sometimes you know features and
sometimes even a headliner might drop
and that's kind of how it is and yeah
your first few open mic so lonely but
you just got to see the humor and just
go up there the first time you do it
it's not even about doing well whether
you don't judge it whether you did good
or bad the first time you go onstage is
just all about having the balls to go up
there when they call your name you know
and if you have the balls to go up there
then you know you got more balls than
95% of people in that situation so just
take that as a victory tape you're set
keep it you know lock it away in a safe
and then someday when you're good at it
you can take it out and just laugh your
ass off at the ship that you that did
this [ __ ] that you attempted I wish I
take my first one I did I mean just to
give you a cue feel better I was
supposed to do five minutes I think I
did about three I walked up there and
the second I saw the microphone I forgot
everything I was going to say and I
started in the middle of the [ __ ] that I
wanted to say and then brought it back
around to the front kind of it I
followed the same pattern of Pulp
Fiction you know what I mean well they
start with that are you [ __ ]
get on the ground on that [ __ ] and
then he goes at the beginning and then
[ __ ] you into
scene that scene I liked Goodfellas same
[ __ ] thing that's alright that's how
my first stand-up set went except unlike
those awesome movies mine was terrible
so just picture if they say was that the
happening if mmm night shamalamadingdong
made that [ __ ] movie the way they
made Pulp Fiction that you know that's
the way my frying to tell you my first
sets up so don't worry about it don't
worry about just go up there and it's
again you gotta find the humor in
bombing there's nothing funny of the
bombing it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's just something undeniably funny
about standing in front of a roomful of
people and just putting it out there
especially if you're high-energy and you
end your joke [ __ ] but at that and
everybody's just [ __ ] staring at you
this yeah you just just this no other
way to describe what a [ __ ] tool you
feel like but everybody's been there you
know bring some water up there you're
going to get dry mouth alright just just
do it man it's you know you'll be fine
you'll be fine [ __ ] it alright last
question alright yes it's actually a
story which I actually find really
interesting okay hey Bella no what the
[ __ ] have my email last week five above
a bra alright here we go okay I don't
damage related this is a real [ __ ]
long one let me try to get to the meat
of this thing okay this is an auto
damage related story all right I must
preface this story with the fact that I
find it very difficult to contain my
temper already I like this story would
even I really difficult to contain my
temper with even the most meaningless
[ __ ] such as stubbing my toe are getting
cut off while driving anyways uh when
something of actual meaning happens to
me having something of mine stolen let's
say I really lose my [ __ ] alright a few
months ago I had an expensive set of
knives missing from my kitchen and I
flew into a rage through deductive
reasoning I concluded it must have been
stolen by one of two people now listen
to the descriptions you can guess where
this story is going he was either a
sketchy Jewish kid who lived upstairs or
be the Mexican repairman who still had a
kid a tacky since I just moved in well
the reasoning part of my temper tantrum
was taking place a few racial slurs may
have slipped out and as one may deduce a
temper tantrum is often accompanied by
loud screaming oh that's great dude okay
the screaming is most often followed by
regret usually concluding with
embarrassment anyhow the following day I
went out to my car which was parked out
front
to gather some belongings in the trunk
when I got to my car I noticed that some
thoughtful neighbor who obviously heard
my screaming the day before notched a
large swastika in the center rear of my
car after a few moments of careful
contemplation I laughed and decided to
keep it there for shameful posterity the
swastika remains as a painful reminder
for me to get a handle on my anger the
steak knives were never found
alright you know I find that [ __ ]
really to be an interesting story
because the guy actually he seems like
you know he's trying to improve himself
as a person you know he knows he has a
temper
and he knows what he did was wrong and I
was a question I have for you guys if
somebody flies in because you know
they're we say that you know yeah I
don't know like your real thoughts come
out and anger I don't know if I like
100% believe that I think when you get
angry sometimes it isn't like you have
this deep-seated hate sometimes you just
you're just trying to hurt the other
person you know if you get mad at some
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean do you
really think that they're out there
sucking dick you know what I mean but
then you got the other side is all of a
sudden once somebody goes into the into
actually you know racial slurs that's
like above and beyond
I know I don't know about that one yeah
that's what I'm asking is it you know
like with somebody if somebody gets mad
in the a you [ __ ] dick like I don't
think that they really think I'm a dick
I think that they're mad at me and they
called me a dick that is does anybody
think that it's possible because this
guy seemed like good dude he left us
wants to go on it he realized our ice
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I got you know
keep my temper in check does anybody
think is it possible that's what I want
to know to lose your [ __ ] and you start
yelling racial slurs and you still stick
it in the same category of like I was
just met AC just calling just calling
you know I don't know I don't [ __ ]
know well you know I think thankfully
you're not famous you know what I mean
it would ended up like Kramer you would
had to go on actually wouldn't had going
on al sharpton show you would have had
to go on Jesus Christ was a Jewish guy
with a bad perm sir a Mexican guy with a
bad perm you know how shopton would do a
lot more for his credibility if you
would really get rid of that pimp
haircut you know what I mean
I always felt he look like Boss Hogg
like it was a if they ever did like the
black Boss Hogg you know meaning honor
that's like the hacky thing to do in
Hollywood like once you're rotted ideas
you just take you know a sitcom like
it's Alice but it's black and then I was
hit I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about this point anyway I got
[ __ ] to do here okay there's a long-ass
podcast as always once again thanks
everybody came out to my Sean Pittsburgh
man was [ __ ] unbelievable I couldn't
I found was there was only like 18
people so I really appreciate it and I
got the comedy works coming up in Denver
judge'll I 31st through August 2nd I
believe I don't have my calendar in
front of me right now
and also I'm going to be at the improv
in Miami in the middle of August and
that's it I'll be added some more dates
today I think I got a month's traded
dates one is in stress factory in New
Jersey
I think I'm doing UMass Amherst with
Charlie Murphy
and I think that's about it but anyways
everybody thanks for listening to these
podcasts I also got a new video I'm
really putting up on YouTube I add a new
video last week if you missed last
week's podcast it's right underneath the
podcast thing it's entitled thank you
because this is what that lady was
yelling at me after every [ __ ]
punchline and I'll be adding another one
scum stuff what random [ __ ] up from my
shows that I do people seem to enjoy it
and it's a way to make you laugh show
you some new stand-up without burning
any bits so so that's it once again
thanks to everybody listens to these
podcasts and please remember to watch my
special on August 23rd on Comedy Central
alright that's it you guys have a good
week
[Music]
Oh
and
[Music]
Oh